[Music]
homeys what as good as the lef koe man I
appreciate you as you can see I'm not in
the podcast studio a little bit
different I had to come down to Atlanta
to do the MBA Twitter show see that's
what this normally is this whole studio
here is usually the show that I do and
I'm gonna be doing it during the entire
NBA Playoffs every now and then check it
out I'll be putting it out on social but
it's just a fun thing and I get to shoot
the [ __ ] and watch the NBA and have a
good time but they were very kind enough
and shout-out to Nick audio Nick send
him down this cool stuff to to bring a
lot of assets down and I get to shoot
this [ __ ] with some NFL players to have
a good time it is NFL Draft week I am
gonna be back in New York Tuesday and
later this week I'm gonna try and get it
out Wednesday so it has more time before
Thursday's shrift a roundtable with
Connor and Matt Miller of stick to
football and we're gonna do a full mock
/gm roundtable where I'm gonna pick
their brains on every single pick to get
you ready for the draft the draft itself
we've done it for five years and now
we're doing it for six in New York me
Miller and Connor go in live for all six
hours during the draft no commercials
like the television broadcast when we
get to pick ten we're not gonna start
talking about Kyle or Maria pick one
we're gonna give you and your team
exactly what you want during the draft
got to interview a bunch of cool people
here but because it's draft week I got
to meet two guys at very different
elements of the draft process one Isaac
nada tight end for Georgia
some people say round two some people
say round three but he's right after it
seems according to the draft experts
that Hawkinson noah fan smith from
alabama crop but talking about what it's
like at the combine what it was like and
then the other guy quincy williams what
you're gonna realize is that i realize
halfway through
that his brother is Quintin Williams and
I'm sure that not a lot of people out
there realized it either
Quintin Williams of my opinion is the
best player in this draft his brother
Quincy went to Murray State he's in the
draft as well so you'll see my face
halfway through I went I was half
embarrassed half excited because this
whole new element came out but both guys
were awesome
definitely hopping to their socials hit
him up and tell them they get they did a
great job so please enjoy this interview
with Isaac Nauta and Quincy Williams
very excited to up-and-coming guys
getting ready for the draft
it is Quincy Williams linebacker Murray
State put his hands in the air
he doesn't [ __ ] care and I got my man
Isaac Nauta tight end Georgia both of
you guys we're thinking second third
round something like that really in the
end my sage advice it doesn't [ __ ]
matter you don't it don't and that's it
matters to people on Twitter it matters
to fans but in the end you just want to
end up in a good spot matters
let's talk combine really quick we were
just talking about it
what do fans not realize about the
combine that sucks for you as an athlete
to go out there like if you want to go
first and we can kind of go around I
would say that the biggest thing that
the fans don't know is you're running on
for four and a half hours of sleep the
whole week Wow for all the days yeah I
mean you're up
I mean I think the latest like I was up
was six what are you talking about in
the morning morning yeah and I was in
bed usually wait wait wait wait what are
you doing that you would need to be up
until 6:00 in the morning no I'm saying
like I would be up at 6:00 that was
probably just I would be up gosh I'd be
in bed usually by one something like
that so it was like up early bed late
all day all we see are the 40 the bench
press but you guys just what going from
room to room and like interviewing teams
and stuff yeah so they have a train
station which is got all the scouts and
and position coaches yeah and you you
walk in and they say I was tight at 11 I
said tighter than 11 checking in and
they grab you in your interview pretty
much all night
what and then you have what are called
official meetings where that's what the
head coach the whole coaching staff 2gm
yeah you walk in they blow an airhorn
walk in 15 minutes
blowing air horn walk out underneath
them I get nervous having conversations
with a brand-new people let alone like
job interviews like what was the
question you got the most I didn't go to
the come on
yeah were you pest but I had a chip on
my shoulder bad dude that's fuel you
know what I mean you know when you run a
four four four I think you're gonna be
wait so were you expecting it small
school guys so I kind of was expecting
you know after the season I had but then
when I didn't get a you know bad mouth
nobody right right right I just kept on
please and then how many people showed
up to the proto you know it was you
really actually do you mind at WKU get
more people there yeah this is fast a so
now I'm realizing big-time school
Georgia Isaac go to the combine Quincy
you're kind of taking the other route
which is trying to get people at the pro
day but in the end it just matters what
you guys put on tape with the eye in the
sky yeah and that's got to feel good too
but I'm sure you're ready for this [ __ ]
to be over have to be yeah what do you
what are your plans to watch the draft
how are you guys are you gonna watch are
you not like what do you guys each think
well I'll be watching it you know I've
watched it since I've been this tall
yeah you know it's crazy to think that
you know it's gonna be me at some point
you know my name is gonna be up on there
and then your name I'm probably gonna
lose it but if your name comes up while
they're in commercial are you a little
bit pissed because you know like in like
second or third row like they'll be in
commercial and it'll be like Nutrisystem
and then it'll be like it comes up and I
like that
biggest part of the moment has seen it
on TV yeah yeah I think I would be a
little upset what do you think oh I'm
being to drive so are you really yeah
corny leaves a top-5 peak so I got to
support my little bro
time out that's is it really your little
brother Courtney was my little brother
oh yeah years of my support and he holy
[ __ ] Quincy so it's complete because I
want to show the seams of the love Co
show to the homies the 33% those that's
what the listeners are the 33 percent
right now you guys are each doing 15 and
a half per set [ __ ]
16 and a half percent so I appreciate
you
we're here in Atlanta we're in the NBA
Twitter Studios they're hooking me up
we got Brantley bringing in guests I
have never met Quincy before and I just
met Isaac I did not realize that Quinn
was your younger brother man you know
holy crap so you don't get invited to
the combine but you go out there and
you're a stud and your younger brother
is in my mind the best player in this
draft I believe that your younger
brother is the best all-around player
[Music]
that's incredible
what is it like to go through and and
kind of share this experience man it's
amazing it makes the process even more
better cuz like now you get to talk to
someone there's doing the same thing
you're doing you get to relate with them
I mean we haven't taken any [ __ ]
together but like when I'm on busy or
visit to like once I was made in the
airport we was going through college I
was leaving the Cardinals and he was
going to the Cardinals he was getting
off the plane and I called them off like
oh my god I think I see someone famous
we just made up a lot of people took
pictures and still it was just it's just
great for real for you all right
specially its platform you know you have
to be talking about the odds that maybe
you get drafted to the same team you
know we talked about getting job to the
same team but we really want to play
against each other we're very very
competitive
really I don't know he frees up the
guard and the red light like you get to
hit the gap like that would be perfect I
do talk about they do now that I know
that you're I see there is a
it's like a hundred percent that's
awesome cooties I mean it'll be a lot of
fun playing lead what's the best advice
that each of you have received whether
it's from a player or a former player to
kind of keep you focused during this
crazy few month period I think the
biggest thing for me is just been enjoy
the journey because I like our whole
lives we try to rush to get to this
point you know meeting goals and now
that we're here I look back on it and I
think like I wish I would have slowed
down a little bit just enjoyed every day
and that's a big big thing to think
about socially now because it's just a
waiting game oh and you'll never go
through this again all right no yeah
yeah what are the best stuff what's the
best advice you've heard this advice I
heard was from I forgot the guys name
but I was on a visa Tom Brady Tom Brady
and he was like this lifestyle of sleep
I think I had a five-hour flight from
Pittsburgh always to Seattle and I had
to wake up the next day six o'clock and
he was like you might will get used to
it you can't little sleep in these games
I was named drop I was talking to my guy
Quinton Nelson and I said what is the
difference between this offseason going
into a second year and last and he goes
I'm finally able to be an adult and I
and I I have my life because you guys
are going through the different type of
training like you're never gonna train
like that again like you're never gonna
train to sprint 40 yards again you're
never gonna work on like your form with
track athletes and stuff now he gets to
just work on moves and he gets to work
on refining his craft where this
offseason for you guys is projection and
all that stuff like it's gonna loosen up
so much and you get to find your city do
we have hopes or do you are you supposed
to not say where you want to go I mean
that's so all over the place and you got
no clue no you know you just you hope in
my opinion I hope great quarterback
I care about the the change of your
positions I actually think it's funny
that you're both at a position that I
think the new NFL is all about Isaac
you're a move tight end you can bring
athleticism to the position and right
now there's a lot of 12 personnel in the
NFL speed at linebacker you know why
that's so important because these
[ __ ] move tight ends and the 12
formation so have you guys noticed the
change our or on these visits our team
saying those things to you guys as well
you know the biggest thing with me year
the game is changing 250 pound
linebackers anymore they don't because I
mean it's a throw first game now you
don't really see too many teams running
so I mean in looking for people who the
speed they can cover now and also fear
to get to experience the firsthand you
know playing and practicing again stroke
one Smith that's all that you know can
remove from sideline to silent like I've
never seen before
yeah you know I got a taste of it you
know and what it's like at the you know
at the next level and you know actually
help prepare me a little better for what
I'm gonna see next but it's just crazy
how much especially on defense with
linebackers how fast they are
you know you don't you don't have guys
that are slow anymore I'm gonna both of
you Isaac first who was a guy that you
faced this year that you go he's gonna
be phenomenal at the next level oh I
would probably say Devon white
linebacker LSU yep he's a guy that he
can run like I said he's a 4-4 guy and
you know he's physical he's a good
tackler was there a story that you you
experienced on the field were you like
wow that's even better than the film I
watched with him
so actually I had to catch on him down
the sideline but as I was running he was
I mean just stuck to me like glue and I
ended up making a back shoulder catch
but in that moment I was like this guy's
really really fast that's a baby
who was the biggest team in Murray State
face this year we face Kentucky so we
got snow yeah but also my guy Josh Allen
what did you think of him watching him
up close and personal the pass rusher Oh
rose face is like a blur really like it
was a blur yeah really
don't you think him very good pass
rusher yeah he's got he's got a natural
like grease eNOS to him that's a
slippery right it's not one move it's
not a hand thing or a jab he just
naturally has that bend a little bit or
just hard to block yeah all right so
you're gonna watch it home yep I'll be
are you watching at home too no you're
gonna be at the draft so you're gonna be
hanging out with are you gonna be
hanging out with your brother at the
table so you're gonna be in the green
room day size people up don't walk in
there and be like no just like literally
like stand in front of like Devon white
endeavor like just so you know like when
you get that first round contract and
you got to sign for five years you know
beyond that four year and you know we'll
see what happens
dude juice it the [ __ ] do you know New
York at all alright so when you come up
to New York I live in New York we'll
hang out I'll show you around I'll give
you a taste
just in case the Giants are Jets draft
you good alright last thing because this
may come out after the giraffe is my
last question since this is gonna come
out afterwards what is your prediction
for the team if it doesn't happen who
[ __ ] cares I can edit it out but if
you get it right you're a genius
so I will take care of you so what is
your project prediction oh now do you
want but who do you think is gonna take
you're just gonna go with the way that
my DM is in my comments look on
everything outpost I'm gonna go with the
Patriots oh I hear they need a new tight
end ok so if it happens you are
clairvoyant how about you what is who
you know they got this guy Dion and I
think you'd be nice to play a lot of
suits way oh right my he's a smaller
faster long back
awesome Isaac nada Quincy Williams
here's the deal
you're officially now part of the left
go show the homies are rooting for you
so homies slide it do not slide into
their DMS get into their mansions hit
them up Twitter on
the Grahams show them the love I
appreciate you guys good luck may your
journey be prosperous and [ __ ] them up
thank you guys
thank you to those two guys they are
awesome I got to interview algae
Crumpler who if you know the left coast
show I believe is my pro player
comparison because I believe that me and
him have very similar midsections and
thighs or both you know larger got a
chance to shoot the [ __ ] with Austin
Hooper that podcast is going to come out
soon my man is hilarious really enjoyed
it and Pro Bowler Kevin by yard for the
Tennessee Titans that's those are all
come out in the next few weeks but we
are in draft mode so again be on the
lookout for the stick to football
roundtable which you drop Wednesday and
check us out YouTube Twitter and the BR
app for the NFL Draft live show I'll be
back in New York regular scheduled
programming you guys are the [ __ ] 33%
love yet home eats and I will holla
holla holla atcha later
lef hey-oh eat man peace out see you
guys and keep rolling because I'm a walk
up